everybody its Grandmaster Ben Feingold
here with chess comm game of the day and
it was a pretty easy game to choose the
game of the day it was the first game in
the finals of the chest Bell Masters
between Magnus Carlsen and onigiri
Magnus won the match yesterday so today
and he had to win it's a four game match
yesterday was tied at two and they
played a couple of blitz games
Magnus won the second blitz game so he
won the match yesterday and this is Game
one today let's look right into it it
was a semi tar ash where white plays
both nights out in the Queen's Gambit
and black plays a very early c5 now
maybe 3040 years ago people would take
with the pawn on d5 and get sort of a
regular tarush variation which Kasparov
used to play in the 80s but nowadays
there's these really long forcing lines
in the semi tarush where black takes
with the knight and place sort of in
Grunfeld style except instead of
attacking the center he just develops
his pieces quickly and tries to equalize
so you see this kind of grünfeld type
position where if black had played g6
and Bishop g7 grünfeld but blacks
already played east six so that's not
going to happen
so instead black trades everything and
tries to equalize that way so we trade
on before we check we trade on d2 and
black is saying look I'm trading
everything I'm gonna develop my pieces
your set is pretty good but I'm not that
afraid of it I'll still attack it now in
the grünfeld black is often attacking on
this diagonal but in a semi tar ash
black attacks on this diagonal so that's
a slight difference there okay and
previous semi tar ashes in this
tournament we saw white playing riggidy
one which is a little unusual Bishop c4
is the more common move okay and
everybody develops their pieces and
castles and what differentiates this
game from other semi tarush games is the
rapidity of Magnus's play Magnus had
deep preparation
in this line I don't know if he prepared
it for this game if this was world
championship prep that he finally got to
use I don't know but he was playing
quickly and confidently and right away
the engine wasn't agreeing with it but
I'm sure he's looked at it with better
engines and his coaches and he was
raring to go after rook see it attacking
the bishop Bishop b3 rook e8 this
position looks like White's a little
better White has the center the plaque
is really solid and immediately Magnus
played rookie three which surprised me
then it's obviously his preparation now
I did live commentary on this game on
chest comm and after Knight f6 somebody
that was in my chat and we have hundreds
of people watching they said d5 was a
novelty so that means that Magnus had
prepared this move but maybe I need to
know it because it's never been played
before I'm not sure if that's true but
if you can't trust your chap then who
can you trust
okay now obviously this pawn is attacked
white could defends in any number of
ways
Bishop c2 Queen d3 rook e1 but he
decided to play d5 and not to trade and
play a boring game which would result
after a takes d5 and maybe Queen d6
blocking the pawn something like this
pretty equal position this pawns knack
in a queen it's pretty well blockaded it
might even get captured later and the
engine says this is about equal Magnus's
idea was more sinister he played the
move e5 his idea is to blockade put the
knight on d4 sacrificing a pawn but this
isolated D pawn is blocking this bishop
making the bishop quite bad and the
White Knight is quite strong and again
Magnus was playing almost immediately
every move because this was his
preparation this d5 e5
okay the Knights attack so he played 94
attacking the Queen once again Magnus
instantly played Queen e1 and the engine
right away doesn't think that white is
better and that's how I knew it was
preparation Magnus
very quickly and he has deeper
preparation than like five seconds of
the engine now this is a very
double-edged kind of position luckily
for us there's a really obvious threat
the rook is pinning the pawn now so rook
takes e4 is the threat and black has
several ways to prevent that he could
move his queen out of the pen
you know Queen c7 Queen e7 or he could
move his knight Knight to c5 Knight to
g5 and Geary thought a long time here
and play Queen c7 that move is
reasonable and once again
Magnus played instantly okay he didn't
think at all in this position obviously
if this wasn't his preparation you know
he would have a 30-second one-minute
thing but he didn't do that he played
Knight to g4 pretty obvious idea Knight
d5 attacks the Queen Knight d6 is a fork
Knight here
he wants to play f3 and kick the night
out that's why he's moving his knight
away from f3 and maybe the rook can
slide over here and we can have sort of
a rook left or as Jenny likes to call it
a rover rook up and over so Black has a
difficult defense here since he doesn't
know the position and we're still in
Magnus's prep and anis knows that he's
like man Magnus is moving instantly
every move what did I walk into okay so
this is the first minor mistake that uh
neech makes the engine wants them to
move his Queen because Knight b5 is
annoying Queen c7 Queen d7 or play rook
g8 which walks out of the fork because
the rooks don't see it anymore
now the obvious move for black that you
may be thinking about right now why is
it you just taking on e5
well then the Knights pinned and when I
play f3 you you can't move your knight
so if you take the pawn on e5 either way
you're gonna lose your knight on e4 it's
gonna be pinned so he played a six on
each two in a very human move and that
stops Knight to b5 however it's not a
computer move the engine doesn't like it
and because of that Magnus probably
didn't analyze a6 it's not an engine
move it's not the first engine move it's
not the second engine move it's not the
third engine move so now Magnus started
thinking he's out of his preparation
this is good news and bad news if Magnus
is out of his prep does that mean he
didn't prep really really deep or does
that mean I just made a bad move
Magnus didn't look at that move the
computer doesn't like it that's more
likely and Aneesh knows that he knows
the first time Magnus thinks in the game
I must have played an on engine move
okay and that's true a six is okay
though it's pretty good for an on engine
move all right now Magnus can play f3
and kick the knight but he started the
attack h4 which is fine
and Giri played rook to d8 which is also
okay f3 attacks the night the night
can't go to g5 because of Magnus is h4
so Knight to c5 the problem is if giri
decides to trade pieces to stop the
attack like Knight takes bishop at some
point
look what's remaining the bishop on b7
not a good Bishop knight on d4 that's a
great night so this is a very difficult
defense for Geary and I didn't say it
before in the video but I'm gonna say it
now Geary was not playing quickly this
is game 15 with a 10 second increment
Magnus moving instantly every move
Geary's thinking a long time Gary had a
huge time disadvantage now he had about
three three and a half minutes and
Magnus still had fifteen minutes left at
least so Magnus has almost all of his
time if not all of his time and Gary's
in time trouble and Magnus has a wicked
attack okay he played h4 played played
h5 Knight f5 is also good and Gary
didn't like this knight on d4 so he
played the move 96 the engine doesn't
like that move tries to trade off the
night
Magnus doesn't want to trade the night
off Magnus plays Knight f5 okay now here
Gary made a big decision and it might be
the losing move Gary made a move which
tries to force a variation to trade a
lot of pieces because he doesn't want to
get checkmated White's gonna play Queens
e3 and attack over here in age six and
ninety-six White's attacking attacking
attacking if whites attack doesn't
doesn't work he can go to work
on the deep on the bishop's on it the
rooks on it this rook can get on it so
white has more than one way to play
black is sitting here in a defensive
mode why am I saying all these bad
things about blacks position why did
black do this while blacks a pawn up
white sacrificed to prime it wasn't
necessarily engine recommended but the
deeper you look you see that white has
excellent compensation for a pawn very
Kasparov like sack upon get compensation
later with your active pieces Geary had
enough of his bad bishop he's like come
on I want to move my bishop so he played
d4 this is a double-edged move because
it helps his bishop but it also helps
Magnus's bishop and it makes the plot
even weaker because after rook d3 this
pawns really attacked a lot of times and
the Queen could go to f2 or h4
D to attack and some more I mean black
has an extra plan if he loses this pawn
then white just has a free attack also
Knight d6 is coming Queen g3 very
difficult position for Geary especially
with the time situation well the engine
loves the knight on e6 defending I agree
and so it wants to play Bishop d5 and
trade pieces that way and white still
has a big advantage because white has 96
y could win his pawn back White's
attacking the black King the black
two-to-one pawn majority that's not
serious right now
so Bishop d5 is the best move in Magnus
has a nice advantage instead Gary played
night c5 probably don't want to play
Knight f6 94 95 96 95 too many Knight
moves ok it's attacking the rook
obviously rook takes d4 they trade and
unfortunately for Geary
he can't win the pawn on e5 because of
his weak back rank that didn't stop my
chat during the live game saying why
does he take out he 5 well if you play
rook takes e5 for example I take the
rook and if you take my queen there's a
back rank checkmate coming so you can't
take the point on e5 because of your
weak back rank unfortunately that's a
good Bishop that's a great night that's
a good rook here comes Queen g3
white hat black has nothing to show for
it blacks thought uppity material
anymore
here he sacrificed that deep one but he
didn't really ease the attack any okay
so Geary took that bishop he thought
that Bishop was too strong and instead
of recapturing which is fine Magnus
decided to attack queen g3 threatening
Queen g7 mate okay you gotta stop Queen
g7 mate you still can't take on e5
there's still the back rank mate trick
now you can't say with the rock cuz your
mate is happening take with a queen
which stops me then you get made in
another way okay it's made everywhere
alright so instead Garry played g6 which
is the best move
Magnus took back now in this position I
would say White's winning but some
grandmasters might say white has a very
large advantage not sure if he's winning
probably okay and the engine says like
+2 even though material is equal okay
because great rook great night nice pawn
here Queen and again the bishop even the
d5 pawn is missing I mean it can't
really no there's no good squares for
that bishop okay now in this position we
saw a terrible blunder from from Geary
which lost the game immediately but I
want to show you a funny variation okay
and I don't think Geary looked at this
move I know that I wouldn't the funny
variation is Bishop takes f3 it's a very
strange room okay and the idea is if you
take with the Queen let's say for
example now you're not pinning this
quantity more so I can take the knight
now we have a queen and rook ending
where at this moment black is a pawn up
both Kings are open the e5 pawn is
really weak the engine actually prefers
black here slightly okay so we take with
the G pawn if you want to win a piece
but that loses the game because of Queen
c1 check and now we play Queen c2 check
and take with the Queen I'm not sure
Geary saw that or not after Bishop takes
f3 the correct move is rook to C for not
taking the bishop and stop being Queen C
one check and the engine says white
should have a winning advantage because
once the Queen moves we can play Knight
d6 attacking the rook the bishops
hanging etc I don't know if Giri saw
Bishop takes f3 it's sort of a tricky
move in time trouble okay instead he
played rook to g8 which is a big blunder
and the reason it's a big blunder is the
Queen is overworked and this is a very
dangerous move rip to d8
the rook needs to be defended by the
Queen why otherwise rook takes D at his
mate so because of that white will do
anything to get rid of this Queen if I
can get rid of that Queen rook takes d8
is main and rip D it's a blunder White
has more than one winning move but
Magnus found the most accurate move okay
which move wins immediately and Magnus
found it very nice move this was the
move of the game he played a six
notice how my queen is attacking your
Queen and if you take my queen I check
mate you now we have some other issues
not only is your Queen hanging that e
pawns looking awful tough each takes f7
e 7 now in my chat today after the game
ended and we were waiting for the next
game one of my people said why didn't
black play Queen b8 okay last thing in
Queen B a man that's harsh doesn't look
too good okay and the engine that says
everything is made Queen g5 Queen h4
Queen f4 is the funniest move moving
towards the Queen and the idea is you
want to play Queen h6 and Queen here
mate okay now I thought in my head and I
still think I could play Queen e5 the
engine isn't giving nap I don't know why
so let's play Queen e5 and that's also
mate I'm threatening checkmate you can't
take my queen because this is made so
even in my head my move that wasn't the
engine move is also made okay this is a
terrible position you have to play G
takes f five and amazingly I can play h6
you still can't take my queen
because this is still made and now
you're gonna have trouble stopping this
made and this made and so forth okay so
after east six Giri played the best way
he checked and he took the rook and now
this is amazing
you don't recapture you simply play e7
and Magnus had to see after queen c1
rook takes that he could play e7 he had
to analyze this correctly now what's it
Magnus analyze not much you can't play
rookie for that's defended you can't
play Queen III you can't play Queen e1
you got to stop b8 you can't let him
play heat it may so the two options are
Queen c6 and Queen ca that's basically
all you have to look at Queen c6 doesn't
make any sense
because my queen can go to the back rank
so queen c8 is probably one of the only
moves that Magnus looked at in this
position in his head when he played e6
because squeeze CH force I need to play
Queen c8 okay and many moves win here
Knight takes is pretty easy but Queen e5
is better
that's what Magnus played threatening me
threatening the rock threatening Knight
h6 MA and threatening EA Queen that's a
lot of threats the main variation is
takes Queen takes takes and here black
snap down too much material but after
Queenie five years now he's down too
much material okay if there wasn't for
Queen e5 White's still winning but it's
closed but now it's not close so Geary
didn't do that Geary played rook h4
check hoping that Knight moves away
stopping Queen g7 mate at night h6 MA
and there's nothing wrong with that but
Magnus played King g3 pretty cute move
not necessary and now I'm gonna queen
with the mate I'm gonna play Queen g7
mate I'm gonna play Knight h6 mate Gary
stop them all that's why he's a super GM
he resigned okay that was a brilliant
game for Magnus he had great opening
preparation which gave him a big time
advantage his attack never let up and
Gary couldn't quite defend with the time
situation he was in and Magnus
all of his pieces to attack even as King
at the end maybe attributes a Nigel
short moving his King up this way well
that was a great game that was the game
of the day it was the only decisive game
in the match
Magnus wins another super GM tournament
not very surprising and he wins pretty
handily congratulations to Magnus
congratulations on only win the
tournament but game of the day even more
important this is Grandmaster been
single for chess calm don't forget to
keep clicking on the videos for more
games of the day and more great videos
from chess comm bye everyone